[Music]
in the world of gaming journals there is
no such thing as coincidence everything
happens for a reason every single line
between the characters is there for a
reason
often foreshadowing main events far in
advance in the world where everything
has the meaning Cassell names are no
different names are not just names after
a bit of research you notice that in all
cases those names mean and symbolize
something in this video we are going to
research the origin and the true meaning
behind the name the ancestral home of
House Stark
Winterfell is a just a made-up name by
its founder bran the Builder who beside
Winterfell also built the wall after the
long night ended 8,000 years ago or is
it just like the wall and all the
castles Sylvester is supposed to mean
and symbolize something most castles of
Westeros have been named after its
location after its founder and even that
there are successful Allegiance although
there are a few castles which name
origins are explained by legend the most
popular castles named after its founder
are Casterly Rock and Harrenhal
Harrenhal a huge castle the largest one
in all of Westeros occupying three times
as much land area as Winterfell although
it's the most still home and is named
after its founder the castle was built
over 300 years ago by house their
only house of the Iron Islands which had
overrun and conquered the Riverlands it
took three generations to construct King
harren the black completed castle and he
arrogantly named it here hall after
himself on the very same day the last
break was late however Aegon Targaryen
and his sisters landed with their army
from Dragonstone in the mouth of the
Blackwater River along with their tweet
reagan's beginning the war of conquest
hiren thought the walls of his massive
castle could withstand any assault but
he did not realize that dragons could
simply fly over them in the burning of
Harrenhal Aegon used his dragon balerion
to roast King harren and all his sons
alive within their own Tower Harrenhal
was blasted with dragon fire and left
half ruined the name of the ancestral
stronghold of House Lannister Casterly
Rock is also coming from its founder
Casserly but also from its rock
formation Rock making it Casterly Rock
The Rock was measured at three times the
height of the wall or the high tower of
whole town and although I was not too
happy with its appearance that you got
to finally seen since 7 I'm still glad
that it saw it least Casterly Rock is
named for the family that ruled it in
age of Heroes the guests release who no
longer exists
the Lannisters traced the rule over it
back to land clever could wreck the cast
early start of their Castle and claimed
it for his own now let's take a look on
the castles that took the name mirror of
its location or because of its location
River and the ancestral house of house
Tully is situated in investor
neverland's
at the confluence of the tumblestone and
redfork rivers River and is a strong
three-sided castle although not
especially large the castle is bordered
on the north by the tumblestone river
and on the south by the red Fork River
while on the west the third side faces a
massive man-made ditch it's easy to see
why named River ran for this castle
another castle name due to its location
is Dragonstone the ancestral seat of
House Targaryen was literally named
after its location Dragonstone is a
castle located on the island of the same
name at the interests of the Blackwater
Bay located below dragon mountain shaped
from stone to look like dragons dragon
stone was the original seat of House
Targaryen investors and had been
colonized and fortified at westernmost
outpost of the Valyrian freehold the
castle was built by the Targaryen some
500 years ago and they settled Island
dragon stone as a trading outpost of the
great Valyrian freehold the island
dragon stone has a small port in a large
castle on it that took the name after
the island it's located on Dragonstone
just like castle dragon stone castle
pike also - the name of the island it's
located on pike is a stronghold and seat
of house Greyjoy located on the island
bank which is one of the seven major
Iron Islands
Castle pike is an ancient stronghold in
the cliff it was built on has been
eroded by sea leaving the tower standing
on stone stacks by his soul that its
original builders and Lords are unknown
according to main search people living
on the island Pike say it was always
called Pike and the castle is named
after the island so the stronghold of
house Greyjoy just like the stronghold
of House Targaryen is named after the
island it's located on although the
graters themselves claimed that it's
satyr way around the next two castles
did little to no explanation
the twins known as the Crossing is the
seat of House Frey in the northern river
lens it consists of two new identical
towers in the fortified bridge over the
green Fork of the river trident
the Freys have held the crossing of the
green fork for six hundred years
beginning when a petty Lord built a
rickety wooden bridge over the nearest
portion of the river it took the family
three generations to complete the bridge
in stone after which they built timber
capes on each bank of the river
since then the phrase have grown wealthy
by charging a heavy toll on all those
who needed to cross the timber capes
have since been replaced by stone these
castles are what gives a stronghold its
name the twins for they are identical we
also have castles across the Westeros
that was named after successful
allegiances such as a stronghold of
house Martell Sunspear in the events of
game Eternals who know the Martel's as
ruling princes of Dorne and Lords of San
spear Witter house being the ruling
house of Dorne but they were not always
that powerful throughout the history
house Martell was
always one of the Great Houses of the
Seven Kingdoms there were times when the
motels were just minor Dornish Lords the
sin shape which is now part of Sunspear
used to be an ancient cape of house
Martell Minor Dornish Lords this changed
when rhoynish warrior queen I Mary
arrived into one metre ten thousand
ships around 700 AC Lord Mortimer tell
the Lord of the sand ship with her and
this alliance of the Martell's with the
Rhoyne are led to the unification of
Dorne in Amira's war to symbolize their
union the original golden spear stage
yellow more smart Ellis combined with
the red Sun schedule of Liberia creating
the red sand Pierce bell golden spear
sigil that house Martell has used as a
jewel ever since it's not the only thing
that symbolizes their union the seat of
the ruling princes and princesses of
Dorne became Sunspear the new castle
which developed around the same ship
Sunspear was named after the union of
the Martell spear with the son of the
Rohner
then we also have a castles which name
origins are legends such as the origin
of storms and the ancestral Sita has
breath uniform a double fortress located
on the southeastern coast of Westeros
overlooking shipbreaker bay one of the
strongest castles in the realm storms
and was one the incest receipt of storm
Kings sub house during then extending
back many thousands of years legend
claims that it was built by the rain
gods grieved the first stone king during
the dawn age pre-cleared the war against
the sea god and goddess of the wind
after they kill his family and guests
ruining his varying to their daughter it
was said that the rain raised six
castles each larger and more formidable
than last but all were destroyed by
storms the mass is seven castle was
named storms n because it was able to
injure the storms some believed this was
because the children of the forest took
the hand in its construction using their
magic in raising the castle walls which
allows it to resist the storms others
believed that the young boy who grew up
to be brained a builder advised the rain
on his construction zones n became the
seat of the rulers to the Stormlands the
storm Kings for millennia until the
Targaryen scheme when Aegon the
Conqueror invaded Westeros he sent his
commander and rumored had brother or his
Baratheon to take storms and the last of
the stone kings led the safety of his
stronghold and met Baratheon in open
battle he was defeated and orys
baratheon to the last from kings from
house during dawn domains sigil motto
and order
becoming the father of house Baratheon
storms and is said to be protected by
spells woven into its variables that
prevent magic for penetrate needs
defenses are passing through it which is
why I'm looking for its appearance in
the final season and it might even be
the best castle for the living to face
the night King from we also have some
key
so names such as Erie or interval whose
name origins meanings are not officially
known as it was not named after its
founder or its location or some
successful agents but if you read all
the history of Westeros all the events
that occurred there you could come to
the origin of it which is the case from
interval about which I'm going to talk
in a minute to understand the origin of
the name of an ancient castle and seat
of how serene Erie you need to take a
look on the Middle Ages dictionary area
is the word that means so large nest of
an eagle or utter bird of prey built
high in a tree or in a cliff area also
means a high or inaccessible place from
which someone can observe what's below
them let me remind you the disturb is
from the Middle Ages and it fits the
historical year Martin was trying to
evoke since cows are in schedule is a
falcon this means that their stronghold
the Erie which is situated in the
mountains of the Moon is try the peak
known as the Giants lands several
thousand feet above the valley below is
essentially their nest let's recap the
castle names we had thus far we have
castles named after its founder such as
Casterly Rock and Harrenhal we have
castles that took the name either of its
location or because of its location such
as Dragonstone River on pike in the
twins castles have also been named that
they're successful agencies such as the
stronghold of house Martell Sunspear we
have castles which name origins are not
officially known but can be explained
with a bit of research such as the
origin of the name Erie we also have
castle names such origins are legends
such as the one of storms end most
emergence of the popular castles have
been officially explained but not
Winterfell Winterfell is not named after
its founder or its location or some
successful agents
there's not even a legend explaining why
name interval for House Stark stronghold
but there's a theory and the theory of
interval is just like Starfall built and
named after the major event that
happened on that very same place starpha
is a castle in Dorne in the ancestral
seat of house Dayne according to legend
star foals built her the first day and
found a magic stone after he followed
the path of a shooting star star fall is
so called because a meteor referred to
as a fallen star which fell out of the
sky nearby almost 2,000 years ago the
Danes forged the sword out of the
meteorite or called dawn
long story short star fall is a castle
raised and named after star that fell at
that place it's basically named after
the major event that happened there and
I believe is the similar case with the
Winterfell as well star might not have
fallen where Winterfell stands but
winter might have does the name
Winterfell eight thousand years before
the Targaryen conquests the winter known
as the long night descended upon the
world and lasted an entire gene
in the midst of this darkness the White
Walkers emerge from an uttermost north
of Westeros the polar regions of the
lands of always winter they wilted
razor-thin sorts of ice and race fights
to fight the living the children forests
and I realized the first men fought
valiantly against them but were driven
southwards by their advance eventually
the first men and the children of
forests formed an alliance and rallied
to defend themselves in a struggle known
as the war for the dawn while workers
were defeated and driven back into the
uttermost North steps were taken to
ensure that the people would never be
caught off guard by an invasion from the
north again brand build a raised wall an
imposing structure of solid ice and
magic
stretching 100 leagues from the west to
east cutting up the lands of always
winter from the remainder of Westeros
the wall a massive fortification
standing 700 feet tall and stretching
from one side of the continent to the
other was constructed along the northern
moon States most of northern Westeros to
bar the Walkers return although it
failed the task it had its purpose
meaning and symbolism we know the brand
builder built both the wall in
Winterfell after the long night past and
so it's impossible that just bran built
a wall to protect the realm from the
future advance of the night king he also
built the castle very Winterfell and
served the long night is to come again
the living would nowhere to face it at a
place where Winterfell before Winterfell
bran the Builder even made sure for
people to know that winter will
eventually come again with phony health
stark and giving in the Moto words
winter is coming the origin and the true
meaning behind our state Winterfell
could and in this series the placer
winter was defeated where Winterfell and
as always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]